Pero lo único que pido
es que no le corro a la justicia Pero le
pido por favor no me maten en la cárcel
déjeme de luchar
con nuestros argumentos
Ese fue el pedido que Alejandro Toledo
que lideró Perú durante el período de
2001 a 2006 Y que ahora tras ser
extraditado de Estados Unidos afrontará
un juicio por corrupción en el caso
odebrecht que la justicia de Perú lleva
de 2017
Toledo es señalado de recibir 35
millones de dólares en conceptos de
soborno por parte de la constructora
brasileña para beneficiarse de la
licitación para la construcción de la
ruta interoceánica Sur que una Perú con
Brasil
declarar fundado el requerimiento de
prisión preventiva planteada por el
Ministerio Público y en consecuencia se
dicta prisión preventiva al investigado
Alejandro Toledo manrique
por el plazo de 18 meses la fiscalía
peruana ha pedido apenas de 20 años y
seis meses de cárcel por la concesión de
los tramos dos y tres treinta y cinco
años por el tramo 4 y 16 años y ocho
meses por el presunto alabado de dinero
en el caso de coteba Toledo es una
figura resonante más de la política
latinoamericana que está envuelta en la
Macro trama de corrupción de odebrecht
específicamente en Perú este asunto
también involucró el sucesor de Toledo
Alan García quien fue investigado hasta
que se quitó la vida en 2019 además la
trama alcanzó a los expresidentes
ollanta humala actualmente en prisión y
a Pedro Pablo kuczynski que pasó varios
años en prisión domiciliaria y se
encuentra a la espera del juicio